I'm curious about the Houston Rockets
remember that was the destination for
LeBron and of course he could play with
Chris Paul his good buddy and then I
started to wonder and I said to Fritzi
you know why don't you reach out to
Jerome Solomon who covers the Rockets
because I wanted to ask him what's more
likely to happen LeBron goes to Houston
or Chris Paul ends up going with LeBron
someplace else he doesn't get his max
deal so Jerome Solomon of the Houston
Chronicle joins us now drone let me just
start there what's more likely to happen
LeBron in Houston or Chris Paul
someplace else let's start with LeBron
and tonight I make Chris Paul came to
Houston he didn't come here on a 1-year
situation there wasn't one to deal and
he wouldn't made that call a year ago to
decide the coming Houston people were
going to be a situation that he was just
passing through town and certainly even
if he was considering that once he got
here he really found out that you know
he was liking him it's the kind of city
that you can a guy like him could make
home and it's a situation where the
media is nice and comfortable we got to
play with a guy James Harden who took a
lot of the heat off of him and you know
as it is we start players after they
leave the game and you have to go to the
press conference he asked the question
why did you lose or why didn't he lead
the team to victory and for the first
time in his career
Chris Paul didn't have to answer that
every night though of course they didn't
lose many games either but he had
another guy to take some share some of
that blame this James Harden want LeBron
to come to town that's an interesting
one it he hasn't said anything about it
specifically obviously because the
season ended and that did come up but he
has talked openly about not being afraid
of having good players on the team on it
basically he wanted Chris Paul big time
he went out and said look I have to have
somebody better on the team than this
and he wants to win that's the most
important thing and that's Chris Paulus
talked about seeing that in James and
maybe he didn't know that until he
really got to play with and throughout
an entire season a hard desire to win
and to to win a championship if he can't
do that
as the team is currently constituted I
mean they came close and gave the
Warriors a serious threat but yeah you'd
be a fool not to watch the best player
in the league to join your fight against
the Warriors so I unless James Harden is
not yeah but does it work how does it
work basketball wise drone with those
three that's the job of Mike D'Antoni
and then Donnie has proved that his
office and his ability to come up with
offensive concepts to match the players
that should be the easy part
I mean we're talking about and you're
not adding the guy who has you know in
the blonde who's afraid of letting
somebody else get the ball and afraid of
moving it around and I mean it
basketball was I mean I just don't think
it's Big Ben issues people made lots of
it a year ago people tried to say that
you know how can Chris Paul and James
Harden play together at both point
guards and how Pat managed to work I
mean there are a lot of possessions in a
basketball game there are a lot of shots
to go around its that should be the
easiest part of it if players are
willing if you have like completely
selfish players you'll have an issue
James Harden is in you know one of the
best leaders in assists in the league
last couple of years since the ADA's
post two point guard he's not too
concerned about that and anything
money-wise they're gonna get paid
wherever they are so that shouldn't be
an issue but basketball was D'Antoni
sister I
he's salivating at the hopes of bringing
in a guy like brought LeBron to fit in
there his schemes you're betting a
week's pay where is LeBron end up it's
just far too long to be optimistic that
Easton would be the choice and there's
some parts that need to be moved and
things that have to happen and you know
and daryl morey is a guy who been
working this for a while now he's right
at the press because I didn't get done I
just I don't see a logical move from the
Brawn James to go somewhere else and
build something from scratch which is
basically what he'd have to do if he
choose to go anywhere else other than
Houston and as smart as the guys on his
as much as he wants to add championships
to his legacy Justin is the place that
gives him the easiest road to doing that
right now
so I would bet you a week of your pad
okay
but did he tour like high schools there
you know there it's like you know Loch
Ness monster where there's a sighting or
Sasquatch oh I I hear that he's a you
know going through the school systems
there in Houston did that happen during
any school in the country that's a walk
off Jerome hey thanks for joining us we
appreciate it and have a good summer
that's a drum Soliman for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]